in einen stunde also lasse ich nicht von
dem hintergrund irritieren ein stativ
ist auch nur einen teller cars heute
es ist ein ganz einfaches video ich
wollte nur 34 minuten lagern was mir
doch wirklich so auf dem herzen liegt
bevor ich morgen diesem sommer sein
realtech heißt das ja ja ich will
eigentlich gar nicht so lang jetzt
irgendwas erzählen kommt ebenfalls zum
thema einfach mal an hat jetzt versuchen
auf jeden fall
ich habe gestern hier diesem teaser
veröffentlicht der kammer ziemlich gut
an hat wahrlich nicht 3000 bleibt hat
auf 200 discs oder so standen auch
wirklich kommentare darunter wie scheiße
das wird eh nicht so wo ich mir gedacht
habe ihr könnt es dann noch gar nicht
sagen ich mein mann hat mich da drei
sekunden lang freiwillig drei sekunden
aber nicht bei der freien oder sonst was
drin nur drei sekunden und wenn dann
leute schreiben das wird ein genauso wie
die ganzen andere youtuber die hat auch
versuchen musik zu machen oder damals
bock drauf haben denk mir so das ist
irgendwie schade ich meine klar youtube
die musik machen sind jetzt immer die
krasseste musiker aber ihr müsst das
auch mal so sind ich meine ich zum
beispiel ich mache jetzt schon so lange
einfach youtube videos über das was
nicht auch wirklich machen was mit sonst
keine ahnung was mit dem kopf kommt und
das ist eigentlich immer das gleiche ich
meiner steht eine kamera und mit der
landmann man versucht halt ein cooles
video warum zu bekommen auch wenn sie
sich immer klappt aber meistens hat
eigentlich schon und ich habe mir
wirklich so für mich selber hey das ist
irgendwie cool so dass es so viele leute
feiern klar aber ich will doch einfach
mal was neues machen
ich persönlich zum beispiel die spiel
seit zehn jahren also spiele ich oder
vor zehn jahren angefangen gitarre zu
spielen
ich habe jetzt halt in gewissermaßen
jetzt auch nicht null plan von musik
also ich kann gitarre spielen gleich
mehr so gut wie früher weil ich es
einfach nicht mehr ich hab mich mal so
die zeit dafür
ab und zu spielt wie mich aber ja darf
ich mir hey mach doch auch mal irgendwas
in diese richtung und ich habe einfach
mega bock darauf gehabt und nur weil
jetzt irgendeinen youtuber da schon mal
was gemacht hat und das nicht so gut
angekommen ist heißt ja nicht dass ich
das nicht machen kann ich meine klar ist
es ein risiko ob es jetzt gut ankommt
oder nicht aber ich hab mir dann
wirklich mega viel mühe gegeben und ich
will das jetzt einfach raus hauen
ich bin mir eigentlich sicher das ist
morgen ziemlich gut ankommen wie advents
10.000 1000 ist ja ich bin ich damit
komplett zufrieden
kein plan aber wenn es mal nicht so gut
ankommen konnte nicht so gut an ich
meine youtube ist auch dazu da auch was
auszuprobieren und ist doch langweilig
wenn ich nicht dass man vor hab ich bock
habe so ihr müsst euch auch nicht drin
mein gott ich habe jetzt auch wenn ich
vor damit geld zu verdienen oder
sonstwas klar man kann darauf langer in
sicht geld verdienen so wenn es jetzt
mehr gas ankommt dann kann ich sagen
nächstes jahr mache ich das noch mal und
dann kann ich das auch für 23 euro
verkaufen oder so klar
das funktioniert aber ich habe jetzt
nicht mit den song morgen geld verdienen
ob diese theorie sind auch schon heute
von euch willkommen da dachte mir lass
mich doch erst mal machen und dann könnt
ihr mehr kann und weiß ist und ich
irgendwie das und das damit erzielen
will
ja auf jeden fall was euch kurz mit
kleinen ihr könnt ja mal sagen was ihr
so davon halte ansonsten kommt morgen 15
und dessen raus würde mich freuen wenn
ihr dann alle direkt ab checkt an alle
die mich da unterstützen weil der mega
cool wenn es auch instagram posten
können oder keine ahnung
einfach netten kommentar steindor nach
oben geben oder so wenn es euch gefällt
wenn nicht dann halt nicht auch okay
ansonsten das lag mir jetzt mal so auf
dem herzen hat sich das sagt man ich
habe einfach bock drauf fertig ist mir
scheißegal wenn irgendwer sagt youtube
mit youtuber du kannst keine musik
warten fertig ja also wie gesagt meine
normalen es kommen natürlich weiter
immer noch genauso wie jetzt es kommt
halt mal was anderes so fertig was dazu
sagen
morgen 14 uhr viel spaß
schönes wochenende euch auch schon
ferien